so the new trailer for the amazing
spider-man 2 came out today and I'm here
to talk about it and yes I am wearing a
Batman Superman shirt because I don't I
don't care I'm gonna go change into a
spider-man shirt to talk about
spider-man you guys know I have a spider
make sure it's in my room now I'm just
gonna wear this there's been a lot of
speculation about this movie of course
because it's a comic book film you know
they've been various leaked photos of
this and that and even a leaked poster
that sort of revealed the Green Goblin
is in this movie it sucks that people
found out because of some really blurry
photo that someone took that there was
other villains not just the Rhino and
electro it's sort of strange the way
they work that out because I don't know
I just was like oh the Green Goblin
again okay I guess Green Goblin hmm
you've done that already pretty recently
- whatever I just feel like the last
time they had three villains in a
spider-man movie it didn't really work
out now let's talk about this trailer
though pros for one I am so pleased with
the way spider-man looks he looks so
much better in this film I was not a fan
of the suit in the original film I
thought it looked like a basketball cut
out into various shapes and not a fan of
it
this suit is classic Spidey I love it
the eye pieces are big like in the
comics it looks great I'm very satisfied
with the way Spidey looks Andrew
Garfield looks great once again as Peter
Parker I thought he did a terrific job
in the film I also am a big fan of Jamie
Foxx I think he's a terrific actor I've
loved him in collateral ray Django
Unchained I'm excited to see how he
takes electro what does bother me is
that this movie looks kind of messy and
I may get some hate for this and that's
fine it's just the way I feel and I
can't like and love every comic book
thing that I see there are gonna be
things that come about then I'm gonna
think you know that that could look a
little bit better one of the things that
I can't believe they're still doing is
all of these villains it's like you
really have a hard time focusing on a
certain character when there are so many
of these giant people in a movie now the
Avengers did it beautifully that was
incredible but there was still only
really one villain in the Avengers you
know it was just really Loki in his arm
yes there were other people that were
mentioned the Chitauri but Loki was the
villain in this movie we have three
villains now in spider-man 3 you
couldn't focus on venom you couldn't
focus on Sandman you
to focus on Harry Osborn's new Goblin II
stupid thing that was horrible and
freakin awful because there was just so
much stuff happening that every
character got nerfed and if you don't
know what that means it means that they
all just got lowered down in quality
because there was no focus and I'm
afraid that the same thing is happening
with this movie and I'm gonna be honest
with you guys it worries me
granted this is just a trailer and I'm
not saying it's awful it looks like it
has fun cool shots and some good action
scenes in there but I am afraid of
bullet time effects with the Rhino
doesn't feel different enough from
Rama's version in my opinion when Batman
Begins came along it was so different
than all the other Batman's that it
worked it was its own thing the amazing
spider-man had so much of the same
material that it didn't feel new or
fresh or revitalized and I'm really
hoping that this one can take it in a
different direction and do what the
first film didn't as I said I may get
hate for this and that's perfectly fine
tell me I'm an idiot that's cool it's
just a movie and this is how I feel
about it I think that there could have
been a lot of improvements with the
first one and I'm afraid that they're
making some of the same mistakes with
this one I'm hoping that they're not
though I'm hoping this is just kind of a
jumbled 'edit trailer it has some great
looking special effects in there Spidey
looks great Andrew Garfield looks great
I'm excited to see what Jamie Foxx does
hopefully Dane DeHaan does a good job
because I really like him as an actor I
think he's extremely talented but Green
Goblin in there with his bleached blond
hair it looks odd to me it just looks
strange odd to see how it goes okay he
could be Hobgoblin maybe it's not
confirmed or anything there's not an
absolute confirmation of any of this
there's just a ton of villains
everywhere and Paul Giamatti is in a
robot suit it could be good I could just
be blowing steam but for the most part I
am skeptical about this movie and we'll
have to see how it goes maybe more
trailers will convince me what do you
guys think of the new trailer for the
amazing spider-man 2 do you guys think
I'm stupid and dumb or do you think they
you know why everyone has their own
opinion that's cool because that would
be the logical thing to do I'm just
kidding I love you guys thanks for
watching and as always if you liked this
you can click right here and get steppen
eyes
[Music]